[Music]
hey y'all
time for tomes of terror again we're
talking about another haunted house
novel
today again just like the last one that
i reviewed which was 12 nights at router
house by jw ocker
this is sort of a haunted house story
but it also kind of has
a twist to it or a different take on it
which i think is kind of cool because
as i mentioned in my last review haunted
house
novels are probably my favorite
sub-genre of
horror and uh you know even though a lot
of them
kind of have a lot of the same tropes
and stuff like that i do feel like
there's still
a lot that can be done with it haunted
house is just scary because it's your
house and it's like you can't
go anywhere and you know it's on it so
today we are talking about the 2004
novel why did i say this book was from
2004
it's actually from 2014 so nyctophobia
by christopher fowler now christopher
fowler is a
british writer and he's written a [ __ ]
ton of books i could not believe like
when i went to his wikipedia page i
think he's written some like
50 novels and like [ __ ] tons of short
stories and he's won all kinds of awards
mostly known for thrillers i think this
is definitely more a haunted house like
a supernatural
type of thing so i would not call this a
thriller by any stretch of the
imagination
before we get really get into it i have
to point this out this is not
this is like such a small thing but for
some reason this just delighted the [ __ ]
out of me i don't know if the hardback
has this
but look at this so the book's called
nyctophobia which if you didn't know
means
fear of the dark essentially now so the
first page is
just black with you know all the things
but look it's like
all black black pages just black and
then look it's like
getting lighter and lighter and lighter
and lighter like for several pages
and then it's black again and for some
reason
i mean it was a little thing but you
guys know how i have
a thing about because i talked about
this when i was talking about that grady
hendrix book horror store which looks
like an ikea catalog
i don't know i just really like little
touches like that because i'm a graphic
designer and i just really like
it's very very satisfying for me when
the theme of the book and the look of
the book
are kind of you know that they take the
time to do something like that
so now this book this is one
where i feel like i'm gonna have to
spoil it
because it's really hard to talk about
if you can't spoil it like what the deal
with the house is
what the thematic thrust of the story is
what it symbolizes
so i think what i'll do is uh as usual
if you don't want to know
jack [ __ ] about the book then obviously
this is not the thing to be watching
because i'm going to talk about what
happens in it
so there'll probably be mild spoilers in
the beginning part but
i will probably spoil the ending just so
i can kind of talk about my feelings
about it
but i will warn you again before that
happens so if you
want to hear kind of like a plot
breakdown and hear a little bit about
how i felt about
it before that and then you can turn it
off like before i spoil what happens at
the end and
you know when you find out what the deal
with the house is so i'm just like
warning you ahead of time but i'll warn
you again before it happens
so this book is basically the main
character uh whose point of view we see
everything from
is this young woman i don't remember if
he says how old she is i think she's i
got the impression she was in her mid to
late
20s and her name is callie shaw callie
which is short for
calico because her mom is an
[ __ ] which we'll get due in a minute
because that's
kind of a little bit of part of the
story about her back story cali
has had a not a very happy life
now evidently when she was a child
her dad molested her and her mom
didn't believe it and essentially chose
the dad over her
so throughout her childhood and teenage
years and even into her early 20s i
think
she had a lot of problems she developed
anorexia she started self-harming
several suicide attempts and i believe
that she was in a
mental hospital at some point in there
and her mom who as i previously said is
a
total total douche never fails to remind
her how much of a failure she is
and that crap you said about your dad
and she's just a terrible terrible
person
i didn't mention too that cali cali is
british just like the protagonist of
this
but most of the story takes place almost
all the story takes place in spain
uh where evidently christopher fowler is
also british and lives in spain part of
the year too so this is kind of like
him writing what he knows i guess so
cali
actually has i guess she went to school
to be an architect and she was
really really good at it and for a while
she worked at an architectural firm in
london
and she's really kind of a big city girl
she's really into that kind of stuff
she has a bunch of friends there and
whatnot because she's kind of got her
[ __ ] together
but then uh it turns out that the firm
that she worked for
went under during an economic downturn
and so she was left at loose ends like
she didn't really know what to do with
herself because she felt like she had
just gotten her [ __ ] together and then
there was this huge setback now right
around this time she goes to this party
for one of her mom's
horrible upper class twit friends or
clients or whoever
and she meets this intriguing and almost
too good to be true
spanish man named mateo now matteo
is older than her i believe
uh i think it's 18 years older but he's
still
you know he's not elderly or anything
like that but he's like 18 years older
than her
and he's uh quite wealthy very good
looking very charming
and uh he was married but i guess he was
divorced and he has a nine-year-old i
think she's nine or ten a daughter named
roberta that they call
bobby who is a delightful child now
callie and mateo fall in love
and so matteo wants
them to move to spain since that's where
he is from now he
he has some kind of business where he
imports
wines and liquor and [ __ ] like that like
into different countries or whatever so
he's like a way on business all the time
so he's kind of one of those urbane like
european businessmen who's like all
young and handsome with like
nice fitting suits and all he's that
kind of dude he's also a little bit
old-fashioned
uh and a catholic you know not like you
know stone the adulterous
catholic but he's you know he's not that
bad
but um callie is reluctant to tell him
too much about her past because at one
point when she was a teenager because of
all the bad [ __ ] she was going through
with her family and
and whatnot she ended up getting
pregnant she got an abortion
and uh as a result of the abortion she
is afraid that she has become infertile
and because mateo wants to start a
family even though he already has
a daughter he wants to start a family
with her and she is afraid to tell him
that that might not be in the cards
so she's kind of still keeping a lot of
things from him now
interestingly their relationship seems
perfect i mean he seems like the perfect
man other than being a little bit
old-fashioned but like i said not in
like a
not in a creepy like cranky kind of you
know you suck kind of way it's not like
that
um he's just very gentlemanly you know
very old-school gentlemanly
so she agrees since you know nothing's
going on in london and she thinks that
she's gonna hate living in this kind of
remote place in spain
but as it turns out he finds this house
although he kind of makes it seem like
because they look at a bunch of houses
in andalusia i think it is and
he has kind of picked out this house for
her but kind of makes her feel like it
was her decision you know what i'm
saying
so they find this house called hyperion
house hyperion am i pronouncing that
right i looked it up and now i can't
remember
i can't remember if i'm pronouncing it
right or not it was like a greek god or
whatever
so this house is really rural and it's
really really unusual
now the most unusual thing about this
particular house was that the dude who
built it
he wanted the whole entire house for
there to be
essentially no shadows or no darkness
so it's all this like it's the
descriptions of it are really
are really good like i could picture it
in my mind it's built kind of up against
a cliff face
like right out in the middle of nowhere
it's like a mansion essentially
and it's kind of all windows and the way
that it's constructed
it gets the sun like through it like
going all the way through it
all the time like all day long so there
are no shadows
anywhere like during the day and then
there's a housekeeper
who lives there is also a gardener but
he doesn't figure into the story all
that much
because he doesn't really come into the
house for reasons which will become
clear later
but the housekeeper is under very strict
rules because she comes with the house
you know the family that
lived there for 100 for 100 years or
however long it was
you know they had all of these uh you
know the relatives that lived there over
the years and once the last one died
there was a like
some kind of will or behest or something
like that that keeps these uh
housekeepers and stuff living there
so she lives there and there's all these
clocks in the house
and as soon as all the clocks go off she
turns all the lights on in a rotation
like she does it every day because the
house is not supposed to have
any darkness in it ever um you know
at any time like except when you're
sleeping and [ __ ] like that
now the dude that built this house did
this because his wife
suffered from nyctophobia a fear of the
dark which cali herself
also suffers from you know because as i
said that's one of the things from her
traumatic upbringing or whatever so it's
weird though because it doesn't really
factor cali's nyctophobia doesn't factor
as much into the story as i thought it
might but i might get into that a little
bit later so they move into this house
and as i said cali
was an architect and she is fascinated
by the house she just can't believe
and she figures out like when she goes
into this one atrium or something
she's like did this house used to be uh
an observatory because the way that this
atrium is built she's like that's very
very much like a lot of old
observatories were and um
she so she starts getting fascinated and
she wants to write a book about the
house
and um you know maybe get back into her
architecture get back into her work so
she starts kind of looking into the
history and there's really not a lot
about it but she does find out that it
was
built or so they think as an
astronomical
uh observatory at some point now
that's not the only weird thing about
the house is that there's no it was
built so that there would be no darkness
or shadows
there is also another like another half
of the house i don't know if it's an
entire half because i think it says that
it was like a third of the size of the
main house
but at the back of the house like right
up against the cliff face like there's
only a few inches between the cliff face
that it's built behind
and the back of the house there is
essentially a mirror
of the front of the house like all the
same rooms and stuff but they're
smaller and the you know the furniture
is shittier
but it's all everything the layout of it
is the same the furniture is the same
it's just like
shittier versions of it so the back half
of the house is like the opposite of the
front it's
it's smaller but it never gets any light
at all because
i don't it's because like the windows
are covered up and like the back of it
is up against the cliff and so like the
sun never gets to it
so it's almost kind of like this weird
smaller meaner
shabbier thing and she when she
eventually opens it and it's really
weird because
the housekeeper is really cagey about
why that's back there because callie's
like well that must be the servant's
quarters
so but the weird thing about it is that
the housekeeper seems very very
reluctant
to give callie the keys to those rooms
basically she's like hey we never go in
there
it's locked up there's nothing in there
it's all yucky and dark and
why on earth would you need the key for
it but callie's trying to like drop her
nuts and be like hey
you know we own this house now and i
don't really want to just live in
part of the like two-thirds of the house
i want to know what the hell is back
there it's like we could put mateo's
wine cellar back there there might be
all kind of
fun [ __ ] going on so she keeps pressing
the housekeeper for
the keys and the housekeeper seems very
very reluctant to hand them over
and uh callie starts to get really
suspicious but finally
she essentially i don't want to say she
bullies the housekeeper into it but she
essentially puts her foot down i was
like look
you know i need the keys to all of this
house this is our house now
deal with it so she finally goes into
the back of the house now as i said she
suffers from nyctophobia so she tries to
go during the day like with a flashlight
and everything because it's really
really dark back there even in the
daytime because all the shutters are you
know painted shut and whatnot
so she goes in there and at first she
just thinks she sees things like weird
shadows and [ __ ]
but as the story goes on
she starts to see people
back there and one
in particular which is kind of like a
woman
who looks all ragged like bedraggled and
stuff and has this weird china mask on
that has a permanent smile
on it so there's
kind of a time during the book where
you're not really sure
if these are ghosts or if she's
going nuts because you know she had a
lot of
trauma and a lot of problems in the past
and maybe she's just wigging out
and so you don't really know she starts
to believe because she kind of starts
out as a skeptic as a lot of people do
in these types of novels
and she starts to believe that
these are the ghosts because she
eventually starts seeing more than one
she sees a male one she sees
a few kid ones and then she's like well
these must be the ghosts of um
the family that used to live here i
think they're the condomine family or
something like that
and she wants to figure out why they're
still here why they're haunting the
house
the weird thing about it though is that
these don't really seem they're not
particularly ghostly like they look like
flesh and blood they look like real
people they act like real people in the
sense that you know they're not going
through walls or any [ __ ] like that they
seem like they're real people
and they seem like they're always in
there now for a while she kind of thinks
she's imagining it but then bobby
uh matteo's nine or ten year old
daughter she sees them too
and they start talking about it and she
doesn't seem all that upset about it
which seems a little weird
but there's a reason for it that you
find out later on
so as i said from this point forward
it's probably going to be
kind of major spoilers so you might not
want to continue any further if this
sounds like an intriguing book
i will say i liked this book i didn't
love it
there was something about it and it's
really really hard to put into words i
think it was so much the
now the story the house itself the
description of the house
the history behind the house i found
that intriguing enough to
carry me through the story like i did
read this in only a day or two so it's
not like it was a slog or anything
i think what i found a little i don't
want to say off-putting because that's
too strong a word
but i think what i found was that
there wasn't really a character that i
could grasp onto you know what i mean i
feel like callie the main character
who everything is from her point of view
i kind of felt like she was a little
underdeveloped maybe um not shallow
necessarily not unlikable
but it's just she didn't i didn't really
get a sense of her as a person
you know what i'm saying she just seemed
like a narrator she didn't really have
much of
a personality i guess and there was
something about that too
that i didn't really understand i didn't
really also get a sense of her and
mateo's relationship
why does mateo love this woman so much
why does she love him so much
it wasn't like i mean he seemed like a
nice dude but he was kind of
gone a lot of the book and when he was
there he also
seemed a little underdeveloped so i
definitely felt like the
characterization was something that was
really
strange to me it's almost kind of like
it was almost kind of like the
characters
were sort of keeping me at arm's length
if that makes any sense it's really
really hard for me to describe what i
mean
and i haven't read any of christopher
fowler's other stuff but apparently his
[ __ ] is like really popular and
he's won a lot of awards and stuff so
maybe it's just me maybe i'm just
approaching it in a weird way but it
does seem like the characterization
the backstory like as i mentioned before
cali's backstory with her dad
um you know sexually molesting her and
her self-harm and her suicide attempts
and her nyctophobia even
is mentioned a couple of times but
i don't know i guess i expected it to be
more
i don't want to say integrated into the
plot it is relevant to the plot it just
seemed like it wasn't
i don't know like there wasn't enough of
it maybe i don't know maybe and maybe
that's just my perception
and i don't want to say that you know i
that i prefer
books that like smack you on the face
with everything like hey
she was abused hey it means this hey
this is a symbol of that
it's like it's fine i don't mind
ambiguous i don't mind low-key i don't
mind understated
but i did kind of feel like the
characters were kind of
a little distant you know what i'm
saying so that's like all i'm saying
so as i mentioned at this point i'm
probably just going to
uh spoil what the deal with this house
is
so it turns out so as i said if you
don't want to know what the
what what the deal with this house is
why it was built and uh
you know what it symbolizes in uh cali
in particular's life then turn it off
now because i'm gonna spoil it
okay okay so essentially this house
was built sort of and it's sort of an
observatory but it was also
built by the guy that built it was kind
of an occultist
and so it had to do with uh i think it
was ursa major i think they built
everything and the
position of the clocks inside the house
was in the shape of that constellation
and they had actually i think that it
turned out
that what she thought was an observatory
in the sense that there used to be a
telescope in there even though she said
that doesn't really look like a
telescope mount
it actually turned out to be a camera
obscura so
the guy that built the house was
essentially projecting
the constellations down so he could like
draw them out and you know make
make his house kind of conform to the
constellation
for some occult purpose now it turned
out too
that the front part of the house which
was the lighted part he actually did
build that for his wife who suffered
from nyctophobia and he wanted her to be
happy there and her
not to have to deal with anything that
she feared which was the dark so he
wanted the house to be lighted all the
time so it would be like a very happy
place for her
however at some point they decided to
build
or he decided to build the back of this
house that was all in darkness
and he consecrated it by
human sacrifice he actually him and some
of his
cronies kidnapped three little girls
from the nearby village hence why all
the villagers are always like suspicious
about the house and who lives there
and don't like to talk about it
sacrifice them under the foundation like
before
the the back part of the house was built
now
what the back part of the house is
is that when you live in the front which
is constantly in the light
everything goes awesome you know what i
mean that's the happy part of the house
however
in the back of the house there is
essentially
a dark copy of you
that is getting [ __ ] on by life
you know what i'm saying so as i said
this is it's a supernatural type of
thing
so you find out later on like toward the
very very end of the book
that the people that callie have been
seeing in the back of the house
that she thought was the condomine
family and in particular the one the
wife
who i can't remember what her name was
elena i think it was elena
he thought she thought it was her
because like she had a mask on and stuff
but it turns out
that it wasn't a ghost it was actually a
dark
copy of her the house
made it so that it would pretty much
take all the shitty things that happened
while she lived in happiness and bliss
in the front of the house
that's what the house was for that's why
the dude
built the [ __ ] in the back that was
supposed to be like the shadow thing
this is where all the bad things go
and happen to these essentially shadow
people versions of ourselves even though
they were actually flesh and blood
people from what i could determine
so all the bad [ __ ] will happen to them
and you will
have a wonderful happy life and no bad
[ __ ] will happen to you while you're in
the front of the house but you can't go
in the back
however because cali was so taken by the
house and was so taken by the mystery
of what was going on back there and who
those people were
she essentially [ __ ] everything up now
there is a point at the halfway
right around the halfway point of the
book where you think
that she has a hallucination that matteo
has been
stung to death by hornets because i
think he's allergic
and there's a hornet's nest like in one
of the old buildings on the property
and all the hornets get out when they
try to destroy the nest and they sting
him to death
now she thinks and then like a few
minutes later he's back normal like why
are you freaking out
it's like you know what nothing happened
i just got here so you think that it was
a hallucination and that's kind of
fueling your uh your belief that maybe
she's losing her mind or whatever
but it turns out that at that point
mateo
actually did die but the house
was trying to keep her happy so it gave
everything back to her
but at that point mateo and
bobby also ended up dying later as well
so the house was trying to
maintain the illusion that her family
was still alive
but because mateo and bobby ended up
dying in real life
they were still there and they were
still flesh and blood
but they could not leave the house they
could pretend to leave the property and
sometimes they told her that they would
oh we're going into town shopping or
we're doing this to the other
but they couldn't actually leave because
they were creations of the house
so that's what this house did so i think
that the whole
theme of the book is that cali
i think her downfall was that because
she had had such a shitty life
leading up to when she met mateo because
when she met him
she couldn't believe that
everything was going so well or that
everything was going so smoothly
so she just kept waiting as a lot of
people do this is a very human thing
to do that you almost feel like you
don't deserve
[ __ ] to go this well so you keep having
stress that
like bad shits could happen you know
what i'm saying so she had that kind of
mindset which kind of made her
you know open the back of the house and
essentially she was trying to let out
what she thought were the ghosts but
then she found out later that it was
actually her
so the house ends up being a symbol of
the darkness or the bad [ __ ] that
happens to you in your life
and how your how it's always like
back there and it's almost kind of like
asking the question
is it better to live in an illusion
where you are entirely happy and nothing
bad happens
or is it better to know about that
dark [ __ ] going to just you know what i
mean it's very it's very much like a
like a dichotomy that the book presents
now i thought this was a really cool
concept
i mean i don't think i've ever read any
other haunted house concept uh
novel that was like this where the house
would essentially
make a dark copy of you that bad [ __ ]
would happen to it was almost like
almost like the picture of dorian gray
now that i'm thinking about it except in
the flesh you know what i mean because
in that book you know obviously
oscar wilde's novel uh you know you you
could go and be
forever youthful and you would never die
and you could do all this
degenerate [ __ ] and you would still look
young and gorgeous
and nothing bad would happen to you but
your painting was getting more and more
like shitty looking because it was
taking all the ravages
of the [ __ ] you had done so it's kind of
like that but on
a person so there so there was a thing
of her there was
um everybody that lived in the house at
whatever time
had a counterpart the house would make a
counterpart of them
that would be in the back you know the
dark mirror of the house
and they were actual flesh and blood
people but they looked all [ __ ] up and
starving and feral and you know some of
the kids were feral and all this other
kind of stuff
just because that was like all the worst
possible [ __ ] or the
[ __ ] that was going to happen to you bad
[ __ ] that was gonna happen to you in
your life
would happen to them instead of you so
you were able to
as long as you stayed in the sunny part
of the house you were allowed to
maintain this illusion in your life
would be
amazing and awesome and all this other
kind of stuff because it was like other
[ __ ] that happened like through there
like i said there was the weird scene
with mateo getting stung by hornets and
then suddenly he's and dying and then
like suddenly he's okay again so i was
like what the [ __ ] the deal with that
there was also a weird scene where like
her horrible mother
who as i said never failed to mention
like what how she had [ __ ] her life up
and it's like what'd you do your hair
and like you're so skinny and you're
you know she was like that kind of
person um she came to visit
and uh her and uh callie had a fight
like it like they usually did
and then much later on even though she
had still she had talked to her mom
after that she was like six weeks after
her mom's visit
she found her mom's rental car
like in a ditch or something like on the
property
it was all covered up by tree branches
and stuff and she was like that's really
weird it's you think that she would have
mentioned
that she wrecked her rental car or would
have come back to the house but she's
like well i've talked to her since then
so she didn't die
or anything so that was really weird too
but it turned out
that later on in the book you found out
that anne the mom
uh had died at that point i don't
remember if she died in the i don't
think she died in an accident
what ended up really happening was that
callie and mateo
killed her because she was being a
jackal
and they just pushed her car down there
so no one would find it i think
now another thing that i will say about
this book and like i said i did like
this book it was solid three and a half
stars i enjoyed it i really really loved
the concept of the house and how it was
described i could really like picture it
but other than the characterization
being very uh
i just i want to say understated it's
just very distant the people didn't
come alive for me they almost seemed a
little bit like even cali whose point of
view were seeing everything through i
never got a sense of her i couldn't see
her in my mind's
eye i couldn't i didn't get a sense of
her as a person as a character
she didn't seem all that distinct so
there was that too
and i feel like some of the [ __ ] that
happened
in the book it was a the way it was
described was a little vague
like even when i got to the end because
i've seen some other reviews of this and
most people seem to like it
um as much as i did but some people
really didn't like it and they're just
like what the [ __ ]
happened at the end because the end is
very ambiguous
um and open-ended so and that pissed
some people off it didn't piss me off
particularly but i did get
there was a thing where some things
happened
that in hindsight were pretty monumental
or pretty important to the plot but the
way they were written about it was
almost kind of like you just skimmed
over it like what like it didn't seem
all that important and like i said i
don't need i'm not dumb i don't need
like signposts being like hey ding ding
ding this is significant or anything
like that
but it just seemed like the way it was
written was very
like it's very very understated and very
low key
so even when monumental [ __ ] happens
when significant [ __ ] happens in the
plot
it's almost kind of like it it's very
easy to just kind of skim over it and
not
and not register you know what i mean
but that said
after i finished the book and figured
out what the deal with the house was
what the house was doing which again was
a little bit vaguely described
so i'm not sure if i'm explaining it
correctly but i'm pretty sure that the
house makes a copy of you
that takes all the [ __ ] that happens in
your life like all the bad stuff
and it takes away from you so you can
live your life in an illusion in the
front of the house i think that's what
that was
going for you know i i don't know it's
just really really hard for me to say so
i
i've this is the only christopher fowler
novel i've read
so i don't know if this is a thing where
a lot of his stuff is this kind of
understated
it's just it's very british it seemed
very british to me
like just in a way that it's very it
seemed very reserved
i guess is the word that i want to use
um and i've had kind of the same thing
with as much as i love
you know ramsay campbell he was another
um you know very classic
british writer that's something that i
found with some of his work as well so
maybe it's just kind of a british thing
um and i did live over there for a
little while and you know so you'd think
that i would be used to it but some
british writers have kind of a very
chilly or a very detached kind of way of
approaching characters approaching you
know the emotions of their characters
so it almost seems like you can't like
you're watching them through a window
or something like you can't really get
inside their heads you can't really so i
kind of got a little bit of that from
this
but as i said um i really really liked
the concept of this
and it was a really compelling read it's
i just love the way it ramped up like
all this
weird [ __ ] that was happening that
seemed like it was unrelated
but then as it went on and you started
putting all the pieces together this is
definitely one
as i said and i say this about a lot of
them that have these types of
endings that this is definitely one that
needs
maybe a second read because i feel like
you miss
out on so many of the details because
they don't seem important at the time
the [ __ ] that happens it seems as i said
as you're going along it just seems like
oh that's a weird thing that happened
and it seems unrelated to other weird
things that are happening
but when you find out at the end and it
kind of all gets tied up together i'm
not sure if it was completely tied up
because i'm not sure if i got the entire
gist of what was going on
but once you know once you have an idea
of what the house is and
and what it does i feel like if you go
back and read it again you would
probably pick up on a lot more
that's probably the case with a lot of
books honestly um especially ones with
kind of
i don't know if i'd call this a twist
ending necessarily i guess it kind of is
but um ones where that have unexpected
endings maybe
like i think it's better to read them
two times before you really get a good
grasp of them so i probably will be
reading this one
at some point again in the future
because as i said i did enjoy it
despite you know some of the things that
i pointed out
so i guess that'll do it for this review
of nyctophobia
by christopher fowler and i'll see you
guys on the next one
bye